a sexual violence in South Africa is out
of control according to some of the
latest estimates at the rape level in
the country is now one of the highest in
the world in one of the latest case is a
23 year old student from Rhodes
University committed suicide in August
after being raped but the girl was
reportedly attacked in May and killed
herself just days before she was meant
to meet with investigators now this
story provoked a wave of criticism not
just at the rising level of rape cases
but also increasing violence on campuses
across the country and while the
authorities say they're trying to deal
with the problem many cases don't even
make it into the spotlight and the men
in this country seem to think that
because there's a patriarchy that means
that they have the power of a woman and
I think that's how the rape culture
starts
[Music]
he was a rich national tennis player and
I was with him for about 18 months
before he raped me in his car one day
next to the tennis courts about two
weeks after the incident I try to tell
my mom about it and she does must be as
a speaking rubbish after a severe bout
of depression I actually try to commit
suicide and I didn't succeed I'm
starting to accept that it did destroy
my life because that's what he did I
mean a snail installed to this day
couple of friends and I took a trip to
Cape Town dance floor we got there I
remember we took shots with some of my
friends and
that's what I remember until I woke up
the next morning and there was
liquid that was not mine that was on my
body
and people have the right to say to me
that I asked for it like who asked for
something that is so painful and I think
he also sees it like that where he said
nothing happened it was fine we had fine
we did our thing life went on bad and
give you permission to touch me
[Music]
maybe I shouldn't have been so open and
friendly and nice I should have gone to
the authorities and spoken about it this
happened so many years ago but I can
guarantee you nothing
to the statement
they are in a sort of a class of their
own but the people from middle class and
lower class that are actually really
suffering these reps and the sexual
abuse maybe aren't always seen we also
have a problem where we've got the SI PS
sometimes losing files losing evidence
we've got that happening in the
hospitals as well and we have a lot of
people who phone in and our foundation
who say that their cases didn't go
through because the evidence was lost
[Music]
I think we have a problem with men
understanding no because the
automatically assumed that we belong to
them for some odd reason no one should
go through something that
you